[Musique]
c'est la photo d'un nouveau né qui
arrache le masque de l'inspectrice y un
regard des clichés qui est devenue
virale sur les réseaux sociaux parce que
beaucoup y ont vu un signe d'espoir
clichés pris par le père du bébé
posté par le gynécologue qui nous laisse
espérer que les masques et bien seront
bientôt de l'histoire ancienne
[Musique]
oui oui j'ai été malade mais maintenant
je sais tu es un malade asymptomatiques
un nom il avait un symptôme programme de
couples aisés qu'à camoufler votre
problème c'est qu'il a fait caca mou
mais qui n'avait pas perdu l'odorat
alors qu'est ce que ces meneurs
golemanas et on embrasse les frères
bogdanoff bas sur les deux joues du coup
la donne en fait là donc pourquoi pour
couper les cheveux
pourquoi pas que ça que tu as fait ta
franches oui les choix effectivement un
body dont quel talent est là la coupe de
sylvester stallone nos jambes ou 3 le
cheveu n'est pas qu'esthétique
il possède aussi des propriétés
insoupçonnées tout d'abord le cheveu et
lipophiles l'ipo le gras
au moyen âge les nobles s'essuyer les
mains à table avec les cheveux de leurs
domestiques
en bretagne à cette même époque
l'ancêtre de lépanges c'était la bouche
de cheveux qui servait à enlever le gras
de nos ustensiles de cuisine
donc maintenant je vais déchets là c'est
un peu les montagnes russes
parce que ça passe ou ça casse ça me
fait peur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui me font pas faire allez
les filles la couture tient très bien
continuer à jouer les durs à cuire il
avait un peu
[Musique]
les femmes mais c'est juste c'est le
monde et tournon comme ça et moi madame
le président s'il vous plaît et mélanie
présidente de la république ça donnerait
quoi
moi j'ai instauré voyage tout un
business pour à laurent les chronos mais
la chute est vite et ckoi wilfrid dans
la vie il est pilote de 2,2 de global
chance d'abord de chasse et puis après
passé dans le civil comme paul otellini
super héros tout autant vous volez de
tân son nhât non parce que lui les dents
du business privé dans les business
jette donc pour les gens pour vous qui
est comme vous qui sont riches
j'aimerais avoir un jet l'enac royal
talent à moi l'humanoïde jalousie mythe
vous les humains datant d'un automne
a été abandonnée en temps de rien batman
va être posée au lavage ton super je
suis daltonien
donc ça pose des problèmes oui ça me
pose de gros problèmes de ressortir d'un
magasin avec des freins qui sont un mets
tabou qui sont pas coordonnées est ce
que vous appelez remets ta ble ssé des
couleurs vraiment apprendre fluo et rose
alors que je suis persuadé que ses cris
enfin des choses comme ça ça peut aller
même plus loin puisque j'ai un gendre et
j'aime me un an avant de m'apercevoir
qu'il était métis sans réelle direction
l'egypte avec cette cérémonie officielle
surprenante torse nu les muscles
saillants et debout sur des véhicules
voici comme ont été présentées les
nouvelles recrues de la police
égyptienne devant le président 6
[Musique]
non ce n'est pas la gay pride comme
s'amuse à imaginer de nombreux
internautes comme ça avec celle ci
conseille ton blanche d'être beau gosse
êtes beau non
nous avons en contre un liégeois qui est
un
il était sympa en plus tous les viégeois
sens un pas et alors qu'en plus je lui
ai dit vous étiez beaucoup plus belles
heures naturel
il a dit alors j'achète une antiquité je
vais la voir alors qu'on y célèbre
marque marque alors grièges marque de
miège je vous embrasse merci mon regard
santoro lui être jouissif de 100 euros
[Musique]
dessinée
dc
tél
et si
je les applique avec les à millau i say
baudimont c'est
regardez ce que l'on peut
[Applaudissements]
restait le respect le respect le respect
le respect le reste le reste on communie
temps le reste et le respect brest l'a
reçu il ya deux trois semaines jean
pierre pernaut qui nous a dit je ne
pouvais pas vous blairer la question
parce que beaucoup séduit et si à
quelqu'un que vous ne pouvez pas blairer
aussi dans le milieu normand moi j'aime
jamais il ya quelqu'un dont je dis je
peux pas le blairer parce que par
exemple jean pierre bouretz jean pierre
pernaut serait pas de rennes que j'aime
plutôt bien jean-pierre non pas parce
que vous le chapiteau jour ni en
revanche que j'aimais pas les sujets qui
traitait mais ça c'est une question de
goût
je
j'espère rester
m
en revanche contrairement à lui je ne me
serais jamais permis de dire je ne peux
pas le blairer s'est passé est ce qu'il
va dire connais pas on connaît pas une
connaissance et sa femme camilla dit que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ceux qui disent qu'il ou elle est partie
sans payer donc elle a envoyé aux
restaurateurs dix ans plus tard à
billets de 50 euros avec une lettre d'
excuses
alors je vous lis juste quelques
quelques mots de cette lettre d excuses
je vous remets cette lettre avec 50
euros pour vous rendre votre argent en
2010 j'avais mangé chez vous avec mes
quatre enfants je venais de sortir d'un
divorce ma situation était désespérée je
suis parti sans payer
j'espère que vous me pardonnerez aller
moi je repars en brasse
brasse papillon brasse en couleurs